our top story it is time to open this
country right away now this is the cover
of the New York Post tomorrow it reads
the Big Apple is dying its streets are
empty tens of thousands of have been
plunged into poverty our leaders have no
plan no answers New Yorkers have or
already learn a social distance
businesses can adjust the elderly and
sick can continue to be isolated but it
needs to end now here's my prediction
New York City New York state leaders
so-called leaders they will not listen
until it's too late
grab your wallets if you live in New
York you're about to get robbed they are
going to rob you because they'll never
be able to get their way out of this
mess they created and by the way the
rioting is already on the wall look at
this new study JPMorgan first reporting
CNBC infection rates have declined and
not increased in states where lock downs
have ended end quote in the absence of
conclusive data these lock downs were
justified initially but millions of
lives were being destroyed with little
consideration that the lock downs might
not only might not only cause economic
devastation but potentially more deaths
than Kovan 19 itself now these endless
one-size-fits-all lockdown orders like
the governor of Michigan they need to
end now right now we know how to do this
we know how to do it safely
Americans are screaming to get their
freedom and their country back and
they're even willing to wear masks in
the appropriate situations Florida got
it right Texas got it right and guess
what now it's time for all the states to
follow their lead and by the way we can
learn from some states that were
successful more importantly we need to
learn from the abject failures meaning
New York New Jersey Pennsylvania
Michigan look at your screen new cases
in Florida are now down 14% since their
reopening new cases in Georgia down by
12% look at this chart tens of thousands
more people lost their lives in New York
than in Florida
tens of thousands tens of thousands more
died in New Jersey thousands more
diet in Michigan thousands more in
Pennsylvania what happened okay
this is where we learn from the dumb
ideas and the dumb policies that were
made in the middle of Corona started in
New York March 25th
remember Florida went out of its way to
get Coppa 19 patients out of nursing
homes protecting the most vulnerable and
the elderly population of that state in
New York March 25th in New Jersey I
believe they did it March 29th
Pennsylvania not to be outdone they did
it on April the 6th Michigan just
screwed it everything up from the
beginning they all forced nursing homes
and long-term care facilities to take in
kovat 19 patients where there were no
Cova 19 patients this policy became a
death sentence for many elderly people
in all of these states and facilities
this was a literal death sentence did
they do it on purpose no I don't think
they did it on purpose did they did it
do it because they're stupid yeah that's
a big part of the reason they have
executive orders all these mandates in
these four states for example New York
New Jersey Pennsylvania Michigan those
dumb policies killed thousands of
patients and the mob and the media by
the way you all governor De Santis a
huge apology because you accused him of
wanting to kill grandma because he
opened Florida's beaches grandma wasn't
going to the beach in her bikini
grandma was sheltering in place because
he already said his national guard and
every state agency to every elderly care
facility and nursing home in the
villages so they were preparing the
whole time guess what they weren't wrong
others were take a look Florida has the
absolute best data so any insinuation
otherwise is just typical partisan
narrative trying to be spun and part of
the reason is that because you got a lot
of people in your profession who wax
poetically for weeks and weeks about our
Florida was going to be just like New
York wait two weeks Florida is going to
be next
just like Italy wait two weeks well hell
were eight weeks away from that and it
doesn't happen we've succeeded and I
think that people just don't want to
recognize it because it challenges their
narrative it challenges their assumption
so now going forward we've learned a
very hard lesson if you protect the
elderly we can save their lives if you
don't then they will die what more
people will die let's do the right thing
we've learned lessons now we've got to
protect those by the way with health
problems we also need to learn as we
reopen from those who never stopped
going to work you know they're not
talking about reopening medical
manufacturing centers farmers are not
talking about reopening Packers are not
talking about reopening truckers are not
talking about reopening the guys that
stock all the shelves in New York are
not talking about reopening those that
work in drugstores in New York and Long
Island they're not talking about
reopening because they never closed
people in the food medical supply chains
they wore masks and they wore gloves and
other PPE and guess what
all the people I've surveyed in all
those stores I go to nobody
contracted Kovan 19 and they kept their
states like New York alive those the
people all stopped working New Yorkers
would have starved to death nobody would
be able to work in any hospital they
kept the shelves full the medical
equipment kept pouring into New York
every single day so we learned from that
success we also learn from failure it's
now time to reopen now sadly Pelosi
probably seemingly wants to drag this
shutdown out on as long as possible
remember her motto never let a good
crisis go to waste and as we speak she
is literally really very busy with two
important tasks one she's writing
another massive socialist spending pill
that will never become law number two
she's obsessively raging about all
things Donald Trump take a look you're
asking me about the appropriateness of
the actions of this President of the
United States so completely
inappropriate in so many ways that it's
almost a given it's like a child who
comes in with mud on their pants or
something that's
what it is they're outside playing
that's where they he comes in with doggy
Doo on his shoes and everybody who works
with him has that on their shoes too now
the 80 year old Pelosi almost makes Joe
Biden seem coherent by comparison almost
what if we start commenting on her looks
the way she's now commenting on other
people's looks I wonder how well that
will go over in the mob and the media
and by the way where do we begin Pelosi
is now using this crisis to funnel money
to some of her favorites one trillion
dollar a blue state bailout as we've
been discussing by the way you said it
Republicans you House Republicans
secretary minuchin Larry Kudlow who will
join us tonight all of you do not give
them one single penny fiscally
responsible states are not responsible
to bailout the fiscally irresponsible
states call your senators for everybody
watching tonight and your Congress men
and women and tell them no way no
bailouts unless it's koban 19 and that's
it and they don't want to open up at
some point they've got to pay for it not
the rest of the country
Pelosi also wants protections for the
marijuana industry say no to that she
wants money for illegal immigrants say
no to that say hell no she wants to
change voting laws a double hell no and
get this Planned Parenthood has already
received eighty million dollars in
federal stimulus funds Planned
Parenthood also launched a forty five
million dollar political arm to defeat
Republicans and President Trump in 2020
I don't think we you the people we the
people the taxpayers should be bailing
out Planned Parenthood when they're
spending forty five million dollars on
political ads even though they say they
will be returning the eighty million
dollars good finally but are you
connecting the dots here essentially
Planned Parenthood's spending a fortune
to elect Democrats and until they got
caught they wanted you we the people to
pay for it all and one of the de facto
leaders of the Democratic Party
congresswoman Acacio Cortez is now
facing a new wave of criticism now
remember she killed off all the
those Amazon jobs that wanted to move
into her district high-paying jobs
career jobs for people well the job
losses are now piling up post kovat 19
in New York
all while Amazon they're hiring hundreds
of thousands